Now, today's internet is experiencing considerable problems. And
growing pains and it's worth bearing some of these
in mind and thinking about them, as many
of them give rise to interesting research problems to
think about as we work through the material
in the course. One of the major problems is
that we're running out of addresses. The current
version of the internet protocol, IPV4, uses 32-bit addresses.
Meaning that the IPV4 internet only has 2 to the 32 IP addresses. Or
about 4 billion IP addresses. Furthermore, these
IP addresses need to be. Allocated hierarchily
and many portions of the IP address
space are not allocated very efficiently. For
example the Massachusetts Institute of Technology has
one two fifty sixth of all the
Internet address space. Another problem is congestion
control. Now congestion control's goal is to match
offered load to available capacity. But one
of the problems with today's congestion control algorithms
is that they have insufficient dynamic range.
They don't work very well over slow and
flaky wireless links and they don't work
very well over very high speed. Intercontinental paths.
Now, some solutions exist but change is hard
and all solutions that are deployed must interact
well with one another. And deployment in some
sense requires some amount of consensus. A third
major problem is routing. Routing is the process
by which those on the internet discover paths
to take to reach another destination. Today's interdomain
routing protocol, BGP, suffers a number of ills,
including a lack of security, ease of misconfiguration,
poor convergence, and non-determinism. But it sort of works
and it's the most critical piece of the internet
infrastructure in some sense because it's the glue that
holds all of the internet service providers together. Another
major problem in today's internet is security. Now while
we're reasonably good at encryption and authentication, we are
not actually so good at turning these mechanisms on.
And we're pretty bad at key management. As
well as deploying secure software and secure configurations.
The fifth major problem is denial of service.
And the internet does a very good job of
transmitting packets to a destination. Even if the
destination doesn't want those packets. This makes it easy
for an attacker to overload servers or network
links to prevent the victim from doing useful work.
Distributed denial of service attacks are particularly commonplace on
today's Internet. Now, the thing that all of those problems
have in common is that they all require changes
to the basic infrastructure. And changing basic infrastructure is really
difficult. It's not even clear what the process is
to achieve consensus on changes. So as we work our
way through the course, it will be interesting to
see the problems that we encounter in each of these
areas, various solutions that have been proposed, and
also to think about ways. In which new
protocols and technologies can be deployed. In later
parts of the course we'll learn about a new
technology called software defined networking, or SDN. That
makes it easier to solve some of these problems
by rolling out new software technologies, protocols, and
other systems to help manage some of these issues.